hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mind your decisions
the international mathematical olympiad
or imo for short is an annual
competition for pre-college students
more than 100 countries participate and
each country sends a team of its six
elite math competitors
on the first day students solve three
questions in four and a half hours and
on the second day they solve another
three questions in four and a half hours
each problem is worth seven points for a
total of 42 points
in 2019 the individual mean score was
about 16 points but there were students
who got a perfect paper with 42 points
this problem comes from day one question
one
let z be the set of integers determine
all functions
f going from z to z
such that for all integers a and b
f of two a plus two times f of b
is equal to f
of f of a plus b
now while this is an incredibly
challenging problem for most of us about
60 percent of these competitors scored a
perfect seven points on this problem
for them this was an easy problem
but for the rest of us this is a very
challenging problem and in this video i
want to give some indication of how you
can solve it
pause the video if you'd like to give it
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so i'll admit i wasn't able to solve
this problem myself so i want to thank
the art of problem solving community
benny boggasel's blog and the red pig
youtube channel
i read solutions on these places and it
helped me understand how to present it
for you
so how can we solve for all functions
over the integers such that this
equality is true
now solving this problem is a little bit
like giving directions from point a to
point b
you're gonna have to calculate a lot of
different routes until you figure out a
good way to go from a to b
just like a gps will show you the
shortest path or path that's easier to
understand i'm going to just present the
solution to you as if we've already done
all the experimentation
there may be other easier ways but this
is just one way that i hope you'll
understand
so we'll get started by trying some
special values
suppose a is equal to zero
we'll take this equation and we'll
substitute in a is equal to zero
we get f of zero plus two times f of b
is equal to f of f of zero plus b
zero plus b simplifies to be b
next we'll consider that this is true
for all integers b
therefore we can substitute the variable
x here and say it's true for all
integers x
now let's try the special value a is
equal to one
so we take our identity and then
substitute a is equal to one
one plus b will be b plus one because
addition is commutative
we're now going to take this f of f of b
plus one and simplify it
how can we do that
we'll look at our first identity we have
a composition of f of f of x
so we substitute in b plus one wherever
we see x
and we end up with f of zero plus two
times f of b plus one
so this will become another identity
now recall that this is true for all
integers b so we'll substitute x here
and we'll just write that it's true for
all integers x
now we're going to manipulate this
equation
we have an x term on the left and a
constant term on the right so we'll
switch them to the other side we'll
bring the constant term to the left side
and the x term to the right side
now we'll divide both sides of this
equation by 2.
notice the right-hand side of the
equation will be the difference of
consecutive terms this is f of x plus 1
minus f of x
the left-hand side of the equation will
be the value of the function at 2 minus
the value of the function at 0 all
divided by 2.
therefore this will be a constant value
and it's true for all integers x
this means we have an arithmetic
progression because the difference of
consecutive terms will be some constant
value
this means f of x can be written as the
linear equation
m times x plus n
we now take this form and substitute it
back into the original equation
we start with f of 2a
then we go to 2 times f of b
and finally we have a composition so
first let's do f of a plus b then let's
do another evaluation of the function
when we do that we end up with the
following equation
we simplify both sides and now how are
we going to figure out m and n
we're going to match coefficients of
like terms so here we have the term a
plus b on the left and a plus b on the
right and this has to be true for all
integers a and b
the only way this is true is if we match
the coefficients 2m and m squared
now we also match the constant terms so
we have 3n is equal to m times n plus n
we have a system of equations
we're going to solve this by considering
each case
so how do we solve 2m is equal to m
squared
well one solution is m is equal to 0.
we're going to substitute that into our
second equation we have 3n is equal to n
and that's only true if n is equal to
zero
the other possibility is that m is equal
to two
in this case we substitute in and get
three n is equal to n so n can be any
integer
and we now have two possibilities for
our solution one will be f of x is equal
to zero and the other is that f of x is
equal to two times x plus n for some
integer n in z
we wanna verify that these actually are
true and substitute them back into our
original equation
we can do that and we'll see that we'll
get equality for both cases
therefore these are the only solutions
either f x is identically 0 or f of x is
equal to two times x plus n for some
constant n
i hope this video gave you some sense of
how to solve an olympiad problem and i
hope it gave you some idea of how
challenging these problems are because
the competitors found this problem to be
on the easy side
thanks for watching and for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]